more stunning testimony from the house
select committee investigating the
january 6th assault for the first time
we saw photos of then vice president
mike pence in a capital garage where he
was taken to hide from the mob the
committee says at one point rioters got
within 40 feet of the vice president the
committee argued at yesterday's hearing
that then president trump's intense
pressure campaign to overturn his 2020
election defeat put pence's life at risk
nicole killian is on capitol hill nicole
good morning any reaction yet from the
former vice president
yeah good morning to you michelle and as
the evidence was presented yesterday the
former vice president was at an event in
ohio but he made no mention of the
hearing or how close violent rioters
came to making good on their threats
[Music]
[Applause]
our democracy came dangerously close to
catastrophe the select committee
investigating the capital attacks at the
events of january 6 were the culmination
of a failed legal scheme to convince
former vice president mike pence to
overturn the 2020 election it was
illegal and unconstitutional the panel
says it originated with a fringe theory
promoted by conservative attorney john
eastman suggesting the vice president
had the power to reject electors and
declare trump the winner i know for a
fact i heard both say that his theory
was crazy i said are you out of your f
in mind this is constitutional mischief
despite repeatedly being told it wasn't
possible the committee says the former
president continued to push the idea
despite pence's objections resulting in
an angry phone call on the morning of
january 6th you'll be a wimp wimp is the
word i remember the conversation was was
pretty heated i hope mike is going to do
the right thing once the capital was
breached
white house 8 say the former president
was notified but continued to tweet mike
pence didn't have the courage to do what
should have been done it felt like he
was pouring gasoline on the fire
has betrayed the united states of
america
the committee says that tweet put
pence's life in danger and revealed new
photos of the underground location in
the capitol where he was evacuated
that's all there was
40 feet between the vice president and
the mob i don't think i was aware that
they were as close as that even after
the riot when pence returned to certify
the election results his adviser said he
got another call from eastman urging him
not to that was
certifiably crazy the committee says
eastman emailed rudy giuliani asking to
be considered for a pardon and when
deposed by the panel this past december
eastman took the fifth more than 100
times
i assert my fifth amendment right
against being compelled to be a witness
against myself
the committee recently obtained new
emails between eastman and conservative
activist jenny thomas who is the wife of
supreme court justice clarence thomas
eastman says it was just about an
election update thomas says she is
willing to talk to the committee which
has now sent her a letter to do just
that tony
the investigation continues nicole thank
you very much